Welcome to episode 199 of the A.B. testing podcast.
I'm Alan.
I'm Brent.
And we have no theme music.
Why are we doing this like like like brains in a funeral?
Dude dude, hey, since the beginning of time, I have set the tone for the A.B. testing
podcast in my intros.
And Brent, the beginning of time, and we have something going on.
There's a reason Brent got confused on my intro.
You know, honestly, we press record and I have no idea what's going to happen.
I have a little bit of an idea what's going to happen today.
We have something a little special planned and we don't know how it's going to turn out.
This is going to be structured winging it, I think.
Ready to turn down.
Structured winging, there's another term for that.
Structured chaos, chaotic, I don't know.
Here's what's going to happen.
It has been 10 years probably since we recorded the very first episode of A.B. testing.
It came out on April 3rd.
We are having a huge party.
Join our Slack group, one of the three.slack.com.
You can find the link on moderntesting.org or my latest five for Friday post.
Probably put it on LinkedIn.
We want to get a bunch of people there.
Basically we're doing a webinar.
Wednesday night we're calling it a podcast.
It's going to be a party and it's going to be fun.
But we're going to do a little back in time, just like Huey Lewis in the news.
And tonight, Brent, do you have anything to say about this?
Do you want to tell us what we're doing?
It was your idea.
Neither Alan nor I.
When was the last time you listened to this?
Ten years ago.
You listened to it?
And remember, the audience doesn't know what this is, Brent.
Did you mean to put each other's thoughts there?
No, I didn't.
But you pretty much choked.
I was leaving mystery.
Oh, I get it.
Yeah, actually, I think actually we recorded it probably two days ago, ten years ago.
Something like that.
Ten years and two days ago, I think most humans would say that.
Yeah, we thought it might be fun.
We had Alex has Alex.
Alex is my oldest son.
Yes. And he gets irritated when I call him Alan.
Alan hasn't listened to it in ten years.
I probably haven't listened to it in eight or nine.
We thought it'd be fun to go back and and on the
penultimate of the one hundred.
We thought it would be fun to go back and listen to episode number one and
potentially mock ourselves insensibly.
Oh, definitely mock ourselves, except for how youthful I sound.
But let's let's get on to that.
So without further ado, and I'm actually one thing, I have listened to the first
15 seconds of this and I will tell you that the intro had a mix a little high
for the first few dozen episodes.
So you might want to turn shit down right now just a little.
Here we go.
There's no voiceover.
Just to fade to nothing.
And then check out.
I'm Alan. I'm here with Brent. Brent, say hi.
Hi, guys. Hey, we are going to be crazy and try and do a podcast because we're
I have no I was going to say we're really stupid.
But what are we, Brent? Why are we doing a podcast?
Well, you know, Alan, we're kind of learning.
Holy crap.
I can barely hear you over you.
Yeah. All right.
I just said let's just go on a little bit.
But yeah, kind of learning and figuring that out.
What we're what we're experimenting on is whether or not this is a medium
that will will help ourselves grow as as communicators and help the test
community around us to learn and adapt and change with these changes that are
coming on. Was that serious?
I was just thinking we just want to listen to ourselves talk for a while
because well, now the funny thing is, brief pause, we've done both.
We have listened to ourselves talk for one hundred ninety episodes since then.
Except for the one you for the one you weren't on.
And then we also have talked about the changes we're seeing.
You continue to see.
Right. And the other one I said is improve as communicators.
Maybe. Yeah, let's go on.
There is definitely a nontrivial bit of that, Alan.
Well, all right, we're going to give it a shot.
Brett and I have a history of having animated conversations at Microsoft.
We thought we'd try and capture some of those and share those with the world
for as many as two, maybe four people.
That's our goal. What's our I don't know if we have guys yet.
I think if we can get three, the architect group that we.
It's three.
This is the funny stuff.
We have three listeners. So you guys to know me, I'm Alan Page.
I've contributed to a few books of software testing,
try and stay active in the community for just about 20 years.
And we want to talk about yourself for a minute.
I am Brent Jensen.
I've been at Microsoft for the last 20 years.
In the last, gosh, five years, I've followed Alan's lead
and been an active blogger.
I'm not quite as attached to to the community as Alan is,
but I'm learning from the master.
I like to do it. You're in trouble.
I like the joke that I currently get tens of views on my blog every week.
But it's OK.
The tens that I get are are an important ones to me.
All right. Number one, it is absolutely weird for me to listen to Microsoft Alan.
Like you've been gone for so long.
I'm like, whoa.
And and as an aside, I still even though I don't even remember
when I stopped blogging, but I still get tens of views every week.
Nice, nice longevity, longevity.
Let's continue.
Some topics on the whiteboard you can't see.
We're going to kind of look at those and put them straight from the whiteboard
and do this every so often and kind of see what happens.
So how should we start this, Brent?
Well, so just just just to carry on from that,
one of the things that Alan and I have been have been really starting
to pick up throughout Microsoft, it's this concept of lean coffee.
And that's how we'll start off these podcasts.
So we'll generate a list.
We may or may not share all of them with you.
And we'll just go through the top in terms of what we think is the high
priority that's of interest.
New blog title, Alan and Brent Lean Coffee Live.
No, I'm the name of the body.
I'm waiting for you now.
I thought it was A.B. testing.
Yeah, I can't hear you when the other things going.
No, it's fine.
Yeah, Lean Coffee Live.
Yeah, the A.B. testing in a way.
You know, I when's the last time you've been doing lean coffee?
I did a virtual lean coffee like last month.
Really? Oh, I haven't been doing my work.
I hadn't even heard the term for like five years, six years.
Well, it's because you're stuck inside the bubble of Microsoft.
People already know everything.
The rest of us are trying to learn stuff.
Yeah, I know, Brent.
Test meetups are the cool new term.
Yeah, you know, so on that theme, I'm.
Maybe both of our our listeners can vote, except it'll be you and I.
Yeah, the thing about A.B.
testing, I like it because it's it's it's about quality, but it contains the word test.
What's wrong with the word test, Brent?
Well, we'll talk about that a bit later.
Let me say in terms of credibility.
Always the best partner that I have done most of my career at Microsoft.
The title that I've worn is test manager for the majority of that career.
I've been in test for I've held just about every position you can have
with the acceptance of director and my partner in crime here has held that title.
Yeah, I was a director with five director.
No, six director parts.
Director's director.
But I don't even like managing people.
The the wow number one.
So I should probably two things to comment on.
One is we definitely had a lot of microphone noise back then.
I sound like I just finished running up 50 flights of stay.
I hear you're youthful and excited.
You've been like the cynicism hasn't washed over you yet.
Yeah, but I'm wheezing for some reason.
I think you weren't you doing like the thing at the pro club
where they beat the crap out of you, that 30.
So the 20 20, I might have been dead.
But yeah, even then I would have recovered.
But so to be clear, like what I've clarified later was I did not want
to manage people at Microsoft because I hated we've been talking.
We just talked about the systems that we made managers go into last episode.
Yeah, directly.
So anyway, let's let's plug away.
I don't even this is fun because I do not remember.
Like, of course, I don't remember this conversation 10 years ago.
So I don't know what I'm going to say.
For one change that has occurred in my life was when I gave up the title of test
and I shifted over to Bing.
Bing is a search and anything that I could give the test community today
as a gift would be the experience I had when I went to Bing.
The the number one thing that I learned is the difference between testing and quality.
When I when I head over to Bing, I took on a dev roll and
but I still wore wore my test hat.
And one of the most important things I learned very quickly in Bing
is how little value bugs are when you're shipping every day in Bing.
Everything changes every single day.
You have every layer of the stack.
Devs changing.
You have the UI changing.
Bing has a seasonality aspect to it in which what's important changes.
So news today is not going to be the same news next week.
And filing a bug just doesn't end up being helpful to to moving the quality forward.
But so I was going to ask a very leading and stupid question.
Isn't it Chester's jobs to find bugs?
It is. Over done.
I don't really think that.
That's a neat thing.
Yeah, the OK, to be clear, to be clear, that was over.
Doug, that was you.
We that was 2014.
Alan jumping in with the fake overdub there.
So actually, I actually I figured out one of the things about my my voice
because I could hear myself back in those days doing presentations.
If I were in front of the presentations from the people,
I'd get instant dry mouth and I'm like, oh, that's what's happening.
In the old days, we sat in a conference room together with microphones
and a little mixer and did our thing.
Yeah, I wasn't nervous about you.
I was nervous about the amorphous, you know, three people.
Two to four. Yeah, two to four people.
We hadn't yet said three, but two to four people. Right.
It's amazing how well we nailed it.
We're right in the right of that range.
When you're in a test manager role, one of the key things that you often
have to do is you got to do things like schedule test passes.
Right. And one of the things that I learned very quickly is is wow,
if I were a test manager on this team, it would simply not work.
We have a a several million test cases that are possible.
And if we were to do a test pass in the amount of time
that it would be valuable, we would need about a million testers
to execute the test pass in about five minutes, because all of that would change.
Once that test pass was done, we would have some useful information
and it would be invalid 10 minutes from now.
But you have a million testers.
That's that's so that leads into the next aspect.
Oh, goddamn, Alan, still in my thunder.
I do it all the time.
But what's funny there is you say as a test manager, I just scheduled test passes.
There's a little bit of a gasp for me.
And that gasp has only gotten louder in the last 10 years from people
talking about scheduling test passes or or filling out test case forms, et cetera.
It's like, oh, God, yes.
Just just grow.
Come to the come to the present.
Come to the new world.
Yeah, no kidding. I.
The the gasp is right on.
I'm like, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I still remember doing that.
God, why we press faster?
All right. I just let's let's continue after me stealing your thunder.
This is kind of that.
You know, it's really interesting is one more meta comment here is
I didn't realize we started we let off episode one talking about this feature
that 10 years later, many people still don't see.
We've gotten better at talking about it.
So we've anyway, interesting.
I didn't realize I thought we just talked about B.S. stuff.
We let right into the stuff that became the principles within,
I don't know, 50 episodes or so.
Yeah, Brent's cat has joined the podcast.
She's upset. I'm not petting her.
Yeah. All right. Let's go.
This doesn't help that I know where Brent's going.
I know what he's thinking.
But there's an intersection.
There's a theme here that we'll probably end up talking about a lot, which is that
how teams approach software engineering and the roles of all disciplines,
especially the roles formerly known as testers are changing quite a bit.
Yeah, that's true. And and one of the one of the themes
that both Alan and I very much agree with is that it's not only changing,
but it's changing significantly for the better that that
my my point of view on this is
I think of James Whitaker's
Whitaker's from years ago.
There he is again where he said all of that testing is getting in the way of quality.
And you mentioned James Whitaker.
There's a whole class of listeners just turned off the podcast.
But we like it. Go on.
So so so we went from two.
They give him shit for 10 years straight.
I don't think James ever listen.
There was a dance at the end. So stay tuned.
Coming back. And it's good thing that this is a maybe my job here
is just knock Brent off his turn of thought the entire time.
Yeah, I've done that for 200 episodes now.
It's amusing for Alan, but I don't know that this is good audio material.
Yes, it is.
It turns out.
It's a limitation that I get to within the first couple of months
to the test managers in Bing where I communicated.
Wow. You guys own is magical.
We had 300 million test cases being executed every day.
This is something as in my prior role of test managers, I could never do.
In addition to that, they were exactly the test cases
that needed to be executed that day.
When you when you're sitting on top of millions of test cases,
one of the challenges is you don't have the muscle to understand
which ones you don't need to execute.
You as a test manager know you are wasting teams time and business value
because you don't have the ability to know which of these test cases have
have no value to execute in this in this in this Bing model.
You do. It was fantastic.
One of the one of the things I want to be clear on, though, a test case
in my in my way of thinking is an input
being applied to some sort of program, an output observed in a judgment being made.
And this was happening.
Three hundred million of these things were happening every single day.
The one of the biggest difference, though, is it was being done by our customer.
And the problem we had.
Hold on, Brad.
Did you make the customers test your software?
All the time.
Sorry, I was mocking people on the Internet
don't understand the difference between customer doing your testing
and getting or not to take data from the way your customers
don't understand the difference between testing and evaluating quality.
Are you talking about checking and testing?
I'm not even going to never mind. Never mind.
I'm just going to hit play.
And is on that last judgment call.
We didn't have all the muscle we really needed to really understand
what call they were making.
What was the judgment?
And as we move into more and more of a quality focus
and away from a testing focus, that's where I personally see us
gaining a lot, a lot of muscle as not only in the industry, but in
particularly in our company.
Cool. We're going to explore that quite a bit more as we
venture down this role of recording us, giving each other crap on the
on the Internet.
So that's enough of me babbling for now, Alan.
What have you been up to lately?
Oh, what was I?
What? So what was I up to?
Well, you're about to say, but
didn't we do this before Microsoft?
Like when did Microsoft kill test?
Oh, this is way before then.
But I think now did we was I still working on Xbox?
I think I was doing the Stupid Science Project, the Android apps
on Windows Phone, which we didn't have testers on that team.
I don't think I was still on Xbox, but I could have been.
No, no, this is 2014.
So I think by 2014, I was in Power BI.
OK, I'd have to look.
I think I was on the Stupid Science Project.
Yeah, because I hadn't gone to teams yet.
No, I was on the Stupid Science Project
because I think Xbox One had shipped.
Oh, hold on. Hold on somewhere.
It was right around the transition of me going from Xbox to Science Project.
But maybe we should just shut up and I can press play.
And maybe I'll say something.
You will probably tell you. Yeah.
Let's check in with younger me and see what I was up to.
God, we're done.
Some people may know I after Xbox One shipped,
I decided to follow my manager because he's a great manager.
Science Project doesn't listen to the science project.
Move over to this small team sort of incubation project, which is under the.
Incubation. I work in the Windows org now, which is a
brings its own set of interesting human interactions and challenges.
Oh, oh, God, that was me so nicely
saying that Windows was filled with a bunch of assholes.
Yeah, you were in Sinofsky's org, weren't you?
No, Sinofsky was. Oh, no, no, no, no.
Post Sinofsky Sinofsky had been booted.
This was the frat boys.
Uh, who was in charge back then?
But I say the frat boys, all of his directs for the frat boys.
I forgotten their names.
Michael Fortin, Chris, somebody.
It was like it was like a boys club of it.
Yeah, I did not like the people I liked my team, my team.
Oh, no, I'm going to tell a quick story here and I'm going to leave.
But I remember this team was made up of a handful of us from Xbox.
Really cool people.
I loved working with them and some people that have worked on Windows Phone.
And we were making this thing.
And there was a dev manager on that team.
God, if you could ever hear my eyes roll like once a frickin day, he would say,
we'd be talking about how to fix something, how to engineer something,
how to architect something.
And when he would lead a sentence by saying, well, on Windows Phone, we'd just shut him out.
So no, no, that means we don't do that.
Whatever you do on Windows Phone, let's do the opposite.
The exact opposite, please.
All right. I'm the way it.
Yeah.
And what we did on Ken was.
There's a reason Brett does not bring up Ken often on the podcast.
We have talked about it.
I don't know what episode. Use your A.I. and go find it.
No, I only I mean, I was the anyway. Anyway, it's.
I'll leave it at that for now.
I was very early on.
It was all secrets, some windows.
And if you are inside or outside of Microsoft,
you've ever heard of the way Microsoft works, hearing the word windows,
making big shifts is either shocking or you don't believe it.
Or you think by a big shift, meaning, you know, we're going to do nothing.
Change the startup screen.
Yeah, we'll change the startup.
That's funny.
So we're changing a lot of the way we do engineering.
Windows is going to try and actually make software like I put it
like the rest of the world does are, you know, our developers,
many who probably have never written a unit test in their life.
We're going to write unit tests, functional tests, integration tests.
I don't know if they ever did one team because it's just damn more efficient
for the author of the code to write those tests.
Holy crap.
I was saying this before Accelerate came out and proved that with data.
I didn't realize I go back 10 years to say it is just more efficient.
Actually, what I say at the time was it's more efficient for developers
to write the unit tests.
I had I don't think I had come around to discovery.
There's a lot of me coaching.
This is actually the first team I did test coaching on.
But coming around to it's more efficient for developers
to write all of the automation.
But I I guess I thought I was much dumber 10 years ago that I am now.
But I'm really just full of the same hot air with different words around it.
We've kind of been saying the same thing.
And by the way, John Devon and Julie Larson Green, John Devon, who actually,
by the way, John Devon lives like two blocks from me.
OK, I'm just sorry.
Sorry, I guess. Yeah.
Yeah. The.
Actually, I liked John.
His direct reports were just a bunch of jerks.
All right, go on.
John was a nice enough guy.
His his ideas were idiotic.
OK, I'm going to push the button.
Now, you know, it was John that did the director of test thing, right?
No, that was so much.
No, you're right.
John, that was John.
So many tests architect.
I was on the team where he tried it out.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, it was.
Yeah. Anyway, I think it was.
It was. I don't want I don't want to flash back too much to Microsoft land,
even though that's just where we're.
No, I'm too because I'm so excited about this because I'm just like,
what's that? It's only been 10 years.
But the world is so different now.
Let's let's listen on and see if that's true.
We want to take advantage of some of the things we've learned
from people like Brent and others who have been in services for a while
and apply some of those concepts to testing desktop software, doing things
like, you know, we're going to we're going to flight, we're going to iterate.
We're going to do all kinds of great things.
I won't go into the details because I'm sure someone will get mad
that the world now knows Windows is going to make software really well.
Didn't work.
But we had this is a big shift for a lot of people.
So we did a quality day, a one day event
where we talked about why we're making the changes, what it means
and what it means for the different disciplines
and how your role kind of changes and lots of examples of that work.
Early on, I worked on the committee for this and early on, we decided that,
well, the original plan was like seven one hour talks.
And whenever I go to every time I go to a conference
and I start sitting in track session after track session, I go, man,
if I ever host a conference, it's all it's going to be all 30 minute or less talks
because, you know, hardly anybody has, you know,
as anything interesting to say for a whole hour.
And there's also the aspect that that Alan is riddled with ADD.
Mm hmm. Hey, Mr.
Pot. Yeah.
So I don't know if project my spread a squirrel anyway.
So we had just trying to throw you out.
You included a flurry of talks.
We had an opening keynote that was 45 minutes.
And then even vice presidents were limited to,
you know, anywhere from 15 to 30 minutes.
We kind of shifted times through the day.
And a couple of amazing things happened.
One was we actually held, you know, more than a thousand people,
close to two thousand people interested for a full day.
And two is, you know, the talks went pretty well.
People felt like they got something out of it.
And that's, you know, I remember nothing
been involved in other conferences at Microsoft.
And this one, I think, was it went really well.
It was it was some talks were 10 minutes.
A lot were 15, a lot were 20.
I don't think I went to the sort of told the story pretty well.
There's our goal, you know, coming out of that was or going into that was
let's have fewer questions, let's generate, let's answer more questions
than we generate and getting rid of ambiguity is always a great way
to help lead change in an organization.
So it went pretty well. I was pretty happy with it.
So optimistic.
I think it's still a long way to go and a lot to learn.
But I think people have an idea of kind of what it means.
Brent's raising his hand. Excuse me, Brent.
Now, before we get to Brent, you know, we talk about the same things,
but I've matured over the last 10 years, actually is in handling
this organizational change and dealing with ambiguity and and just having more influence.
Yeah, yeah. You in the last 10 years, you scaled and affected change.
Like, like I think about what you learned when you went over to unity.
You were quite a high level when you left Microsoft.
And yet I still don't think you would have had the impact.
No, and I think, you know, I I had to leave.
I didn't have to leave, but I had believed to do what I did grow where I wanted to grow.
So it's been great.
All right. I can't wait to hear what you had your hand up.
And what do you think?
10 years ago, Brent said, let's find out.
Burt.
Wow. First one, we're going to go that way.
That's an inside joke. We'll talk about that later.
So you said something that I think is super interesting to me anyway.
So you said that it went really well.
Did you happen to talk with a bunch of people?
I'm curious what were sort of the top five themes that came out of that,
that really resonated with folks.
The first thing I heard, the thing I heard foremost was the format worked.
And that's I was involved in that change.
I was happy to hear that.
As far as people taking away things, there is, you know, at Microsoft,
we have this three discipline system.
We have program management.
We have software development and software test,
which we call quality in Windows now, but it's the same thing.
Trying to shift the mindset by the title.
I completely forgot about that.
Do you remember that?
So we had the quality and fundamentals group and we.
Yeah.
It was a lot of, it was.
And we need to control.
Far too much. But yeah, it was spin control.
They still had a quality team.
Those folks are all gone now, but they focused on data.
And that's what a lot of folks in Windows like.
That's when Steve, former guest a few times on the show.
Right.
He's really deep into the data science world.
As far as I know, I don't know if he was still there anymore,
but he cut a lot of a lot of folks from test went that direction.
Some went to Deb, some left.
But yeah, I forgot about the quality group.
The three pronged.
In hindsight, I realized now I didn't know at the time how
wrong the whole approach was because I was in the middle of it.
And as much as you know, I paid more attention to what happened
outside of Microsoft than a lot of people at Microsoft.
But it wasn't until I left and kind of saw more that I really
began to see a bigger picture.
Yeah.
Brent just stabbed himself.
So, uh,
10 years later, you stabbed himself.
That's funny.
There was a good one of the things I love to do when I'm like getting
a new team put together is get the discipline leadership together.
I talk about what their team does, what their expectations are for
other people.
And this was like a big forum version of that.
In talking through what the roles did, we had we had a lot of
opportunity for everyone in the room, all engineering disciplines
to understand what each other was responsible for and what they
were, what new things they were responsible for.
So everybody's kind of in it together.
That was another big theme that came out.
And people loved.
I'll do the third theme.
People love this.
We had a ton of examples of where data driven quality has
worked and where, you know, making not just the business
intelligence part of understanding how users using the software,
but building statistical models on our analysis and using that to
make predictions on how customers have used software and examples
of that, like I think the scales shed people's eyes and they
thought, Hey, I think I get how this can work, which if you
work in an org like windows is a huge, huge thing.
It's a, I'll just say it's a team deeply rooted in history.
I was far too optimistic, but they are, they have a far
far far far too optimistic.
It didn't, I thought at the time I thought, man, yeah, it's going to be
so great.
And it's still a moving ship.
Were you optimistic or were you just at a phase where like, okay,
first episode, it's hard to tell.
It's listening to younger me.
It sounds like I believed it, but I could have just been trying to
tell a good story.
I feel like you were a good story.
I could have just been trying to tell a good story.
I feel like you're, you're being careful.
Uh, right.
It's the first thing.
Okay.
We're already talking about Microsoft.
I don't know either.
I've been talking a lot about Microsoft over the years.
So yeah, I don't know.
We both have, but I'm so employed there.
So I'm still very careful, but yeah, I think it was our
first episode where we were like extra careful.
I don't know.
Nobody.
And I'm sure you've heard nothing since, since I left,
but we never got caught.
I don't think a single person who cared at Microsoft,
listen to our podcast.
I've got one reach out from HR.
Oh, uh, I don't know,
like seven years ago and they just wanted to confirm that,
that it was me.
Nothing else came out of it.
I guess.
Interesting.
I guess I showed up and yeah.
Anyway,
it showed up in my permanent record somehow.
All right.
Brett.
Yeah.
The fine tradition.
Um,
of producing really great code at a,
at a really great cadence.
The,
the one thing I might say to our competitors is this,
despite what you think about windows,
our people,
we have a large number of people and they are really good at execution.
Once this culture shifts,
they're going to be really good at this new culture.
Or careful.
Absolutely.
Correct.
Um,
we have good executor.
And when,
when the hammer did finally fall,
right?
It,
it was either,
I look back at it now and there's,
there was really two people,
two kinds of people,
the people who started executing and the white knuckle folks who were like,
no,
same with any organizational change though, right?
That's true.
Yeah.
Same back then.
It is.
We, um,
anyway,
I don't want to get up on the Microsoft raw,
raw band,
but we have a ton of work to do and,
um,
sometimes it's frustrating,
but,
uh,
it's,
um,
yeah,
it's interesting to be part of this change right now.
I,
I haven't seen a more exciting time in my career,
uh,
than the time we were,
we're in right now.
I think that I wonder if that's true across the industry.
You know,
I think we're talking about some of this stuff and we're going to wrap up in a
minute here.
For those of you that are extremely boring,
I remember talking about some of this stuff just about a year ago about,
you know,
some of the changes we're making on my,
I think it was,
I think I was on Xbox then.
Sorry.
I had to think for a second.
And it's been a blur.
So just so you guys know,
Alan spent five years last year in Xbox.
Yes,
I did.
It's all a blur.
Um,
I should've got an extra five,
five year service award just for the my two years in Xbox.
Yeah.
Um,
wait, so where were you?
But I described some of the things,
you know,
right.
This is where,
where were you then then?
During this talk.
Oh no, that's right.
You were,
you were on science fair project.
We just had this conversation.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go.
We need to go.
It's cutting edge that I remember talking to someone outside of
Microsoft and the quote was,
uh,
this would all be revolutionary if it weren't already happening.
And,
uh,
I remember that.
I remember that going,
oh,
you and I talk about like maybe we're on the edge of the bubble,
but we're not.
There's always people ahead of us.
And I can't remember who said that to me,
but that quote has stuck with me for a long,
long time.
Right.
I mean,
it isn't for,
uh,
we did around,
it wouldn't be for another three and a half years before we would do
modern testing principles.
Could have been.
We had to talk about still end up.
We vetted it out for a long time.
And again,
we're just at bay.
Anyway,
anyway,
love that comment.
I feel like,
I feel like people keep telling me that,
but I've kept it in episode one.
It's weird.
It right.
Reminds me a bit of,
um,
a comment.
What was one of the books?
Oh,
exploratory testing.
I was,
I have,
um,
I have a book there on my shelf.
They're all my sign books,
including yours and all of them I have from Whitaker.
That Whitaker's exploring her testing book.
Yes.
And I,
the best part of that book is the forward.
The forward is like the most masterful writing in there.
Um,
yes.
I do know who wrote the forward.
I am just moving on.
Um,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Um,
uh,
I remember.
So James and I would do monthly lunches,
uh,
back then.
And I remember going to lunch with him and I'm like,
James,
this book is,
is just like a span on how to break software.
He's like,
he's looked at me and he just smiles.
yeah.
I mean,
if they're not learning in 10 years,
like I can just bring it all back and act like it's new.
I'm like,
okay.
All right.
Let's,
let's check out the riveting conclusion of episode one.
I'm glad to get into the world here and I,
you know, I'm excited.
It's a fun time to be here.
The positive thing for our company in this,
in this front is that it is already happening.
There's a lots of examples.
Um,
we're well motivated,
uh,
because our,
we were so Microsoft or succeeding with this type of model where we're
still struggling.
That's a lot of words.
They were getting our butts kicked.
Yeah.
Yes.
All right.
I think that's enough for today.
We have lots more to talk about,
but we'll get to it next time.
Our lean coffee list is not exhausted.
Uh,
I'm Alan.
Thanks for listening.
And I'm Brent and have a fantastic week.
In my dreams.
So,
uh,
okay.
A couple of metacommas,
we can call it good.
So one,
I sound young and didn't realize I was so optimistic.
And I was going to try not to edit this one too much,
but I have to go edit out your typing now.
So,
so thanks a lot.
You bet.
Um,
yeah, overall.
Uh,
okay.
Horrible,
but it was fun to listen to.
I was just thinking about something because so Sinovski left in 2012.
Okay.
And we recorded this in April 2014.
And bomber left in 2014.
And I'm like, okay, where was,
I'm trying to see the exact month.
Were we still under the,
the Yoka bomber when we recorded that?
Because a lot of the things,
a lot of the things I think that like,
it took him forever to realize that we needed to shift to agile.
Like, um,
you remember how he did the road show amongst all the high level.
Yeah.
Yep.
And I remember, um,
the last several of them, he was like, we gotta get more agile.
We gotta get, I'm like,
and he was trying to do like the developer, developer, developer thing,
but with agile,
but it was very clear.
He did not understand what it meant.
It, right.
He was,
he grew into the position well,
but you know,
one of the reasons I left it wasn't changing fast enough for me,
but I think he, it took him,
you know,
a year or more of being in that role to kind of figure out what he really
wanted to do.
And then, um, you know, uh,
just, just, just didn't get there for me.
But yeah, I remember the time it's so weird.
It seemed, and some,
it feels like a couple of years ago and 20 years ago,
both at once.
Right.
Cause I can't do date math.
All right. Any other comments from you?
August, August 2014.
So, so, so yeah, we, we were, um,
yeah, we were like, yeah,
these other companies are stealing our candy and that was 100% because
we, we hadn't executed a shift.
Yeah.
Things had to get a little worse for the guy.
And it's interesting.
Look, I, you and I both have spent the better part of the last 10
years working in the service space and yet still,
still many of the things we say today, we say, we said on that episode.
Yeah.
The cloud may catch on.
People may use the cloud and still, still go in that direction.
Right.
It, it, it, I keep dreaming.
It'll be a thing one day.
That's why I keep investing in it.
All right.
Well, let's call that good.
I am.
That would help the listeners.
You had fun there and please come hang out with us Wednesday night.
Links to be found on the internet somewhere.
I'll help you find them Thursday morning, depending on the time.
You can listen to the recording Thursday morning.
Yeah.
Another big apology to all of our listeners in Europe.
The best time for Brent and I to record was our evening,
which is middle of the night for our friends across the Atlantic.
So it'll be ready for you when you get up.
Cause I plan on just fixing voice levels and releasing that one right
after we're done.
So it'll be out.
Should I show you how to post it to your podcast apps within 20 or 30
minutes after the recording is done.
Oh, you're going straight to straight.
I'm not going to edit anything.
I'm going to leave it all there.
Hopefully it'll have to put an explicit tag on it.
But you never know.
I might be drinking some champagne.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah.
All right, everybody.
This was episode one.
Ninety nine.
Sorry.
Yeah.
One ninety nine one.
But it was one with one ninety nine.
All right.
I'm out.
Yeah.
I'm Brent.
I'll see you later.